>> One of the major problems that we have
is that as global citizens,
we have the wrong values.
As global citizens, we have the wrong systems.
And we have the wrong -- or rather inappropriate
institutions.
And as our core business and our agenda for
the next ten years should
be about rethinking our values, should be
about redesigning our
systems, should be about rebuilding our institutions.
And if we are successful, one very innovative
product, one very
innovative development is if we can come up
with a new global
governance system, where there's total buy-in
and ownership by all the
countries of the world, and this new global
governing system cannot be
business as usual.
It mean we need to rethink, redesign, and
rebuild the United Nations.
We need to rethink, redesign, and rebuild
the IMF, the World Bank-type
institutions, to do away with those institutions
and to craft new ones.
You can not solve new problems by using old
solutions.
Or rather you cannot solve a problem by using
the tools or instruments
that led to the creation of those problems.
So hence, in the next ten years our target
should be to say how do we
accept that global challenges are interdependent.
Now do we accept that global challenges are
interconnected and nations
today are more interdependent than than independent.
How do we come up with the position that says
you can resolve the
challenges of climate change in America or
Europe without addressing
them in Africa?
You can't address HIV and AIDS, poverty in
Africa without making sure
there is involvement and participation by
all global players.
In other words, all global challenges must
be addressed in a global
manner, meaning global solutions for global
problems.
And also, we must make sure in this global
governance system, Africans
become players.
Africans are sick and tired of being consumers
of knowledge.
Africans are sick and tired of being at the
receiving end of ideas.
We must make sure Africans and those from
poor countries are
participants in the crafting of the solutions.
For example, as we address the global financial
crisis, where is the
African input?
Where is the additional of Asia? Of India?
We must make sure that we don't resort back
to economic nationalism
where America is looking after America where
Europe is doing the same.
We must sit down as global citizens and be
able to craft truly global
governance system where there's buy-in and
ownership by the generality
of the global community.
And this should be a major innovation if we
achieve it, in the next ten
years.